- There's a robot company up on a hill
in this small coastal town
in the south-west of England.
They got in touch with me and asked
if wanted to come and
look at their robots.
And I said, "Oh yeah, I've heard of you,
"you make really impressive robots,
"but they're not really that much of
a story for my channel on their own."
So I said, "look, one of the things you do
"is you make robot doubles of people
"for shows and attractions
and publicity stunts.
"Could you make a robot double of me?"
And they said they could...
but it would cost quite a bit of money.
- We create humanoid robots
such as the ones behind me.
Entertainment, communication and education
are the main use cases
for this type of robot.
We've been creating
robots for over 15 years,
and in that time the technology
has obviously progressed.
Robothespian was our first humanoid robot,
and that was very plasticy.
After Robothespian, we
started to create Mesmer.
Mesmer is our
ultra-lifelike-looking robot.
So it has the skin, it's painted
like a human, we have hair,
and then we also dress them like a human,
and they're of the human form.
And then when we created
Ameca, our newest robot,
that's when we thought:
we need more facial expressions.
So we increased the number
of motors in the head.
There's more brow movements,
it's got inner and outer brow,
we've got a nose wrinkle,
and we've got better movement in the lips.
The problem we have is the uncanny valley.
You get that uncanny resemblance,
but it's not quite right.
And again, it's not just
the what-it-looks-like,
it's also how it moves.
And that's where it gets creepy,
that's where it gets scary.
We can create any person in robot form.
So we can create a
Mesmer of you or anyone.
- Okay, so I want them to
build the robot double,
not as a permanent thing,
but it'd be great as a one-off,
like, that's a great video idea.
But what would I do with it?
And besides, even just
the parts and labour
for making the big mask
and attaching it to
an existing bot for
one day's filming...
that's not cheap.
So back in 2019, I did a video
about the advertising for
VPNs, virtual private networks.
If you watch much YouTube,
you will probably have seen
an advert for VPNs at some point.
And in 2019, some of those adverts were...
well, "lying" is a strong term,
but certainly stretching the truth a bit,
and I made a video about that.
Turns out that video worked
better than I thought,
no one's making those claims anymore.
I have heard rumours
that there were several
quite awkward conversations
between VPN companies and the
people advertising for them.
That video changed the industry,
it changed how VPNs were sold.
And it also cut me off from
being able to advertise them.
Partly because companies were wary of me,
partly because a lot of people
didn't quite pay attention to the video.
I wasn't saying VPNs were bad,
just that VPN advertising was bad.
There are valid reasons to use VPNs,
I said so in the video.
"Those are valid uses of VPNs."
But I burned that bridge,
I couldn't advertise VPNs.
You've probably already worked out
where this is going by now?
Inside the robot factory is my double,
and it's going to do
the sponsor read for me.
I haven't met it yet.
A few months ago, I was here
to get my head 3D-scanned,
but that's all I know.
I haven't even seen a picture
of the final result yet.
I'm just going to take this
GoPro camera in on a stick,
and meet myself.
- So to create the Tom Scott bot,
we actually got Tom Scott
to sit in a scanning rig,
took a scan of Tom,
and then we 3D sculpt that.
So first we clean up the scan,
3D sculpt the actual person
that we are creating.
And then when we've got that,
we have to design the
mechanics that fit inside.
We have a 3D printed skull,
over the top of the mechanics
which of course are made out of metal.
The Tom Scott bot is
head and shoulders only.
So we got his head, we got a neck,
but there's no body underneath.
Once we created the robot,
we'd scan that robot again,
and using that scan we know exactly
the range of motions of the robot.
We then do a video of the person,
or get some reference
videos of the person,
and try and match their
little here-and-there
with the mouth and the eyes.
Everyone's different the way
they actually express themselves,
we try and match those.
- Hello?
- Hi Tom, how are you doing?
- How are you?
- Yeah, good thanks.
- A bit nervous!
- Are you ready for this?
[laughs]
- I honestly, I don't know
how I feel about this.
I really, I really don't.
You said it was through
there on the right.
- It's through here,
so go ahead, you first.
- Okay.
Oh, that is weird.
[laughter]
That is really, wow.
[laughs]
Do you want to take that camera?
That is, oh wow.
I actually sort of rehearsed
things to say at this point.
Uh, no, I... wow.
That is...
[laughs]
it's going to be even weirder
when it's got my voice
coming out of it.
Who did the artistry on the
skin, 'cause the air brushing,
however it's printed, airbrushed...
how do you do it?
- Yeah, it's actually silicone paint
and our creative guy, Mike,
painted your whole skin.
And then each one of those
hairs, is a human hair,
and each one is individually
punched one by one by hand.
- Good grief. That is...
- Yes.
- I think more so for me.
- Because I, like this is
not looking into the mirror,
this is looking into a very weird mirror.
- Yes, exactly.
When you look into a mirror,
you see a mirrored image of yourself.
This is not a mirrored image,
this is the other way.
- Oh! It is.
- It's always going to look
even more weird to you.
- Yeah.
It just did a thing,
and I assume it's just
on a cycle right now.
- It is at the minute, yes.
- So it just did a thing
where it just looked at me,
and for a moment I made eye contact,
and just from... there!
Just for a moment, my brain went:
"person".
- It's alive.
- It just, it hit that for
just a second in my head.
- There's moments when I just look at it
from an angle... from this angle?
My brain goes, "that's me".
[concerned noise]
Ah, I just...
[laughter]
It's really rare that I'm
lost for words, and I...
this is such a surreal experience.
Right, okay, let's do the advert.
- Okay, cool.
- Off we go.
- There are good reasons to use a VPN,
and I recommend NordVPN,
who are sponsoring this video.
In some countries, it's legal
for your internet provider
to slow down your connection
depending on what you're looking at,
or to record what sites you visit
to build up a creepy
advertising profile about you
that they can sell.
NordVPN can stop all that.
Or maybe you're on the road,
travelling to another country,
and still want to watch the
shows that you're used to.
NordVPN can give you a spoofed location
in any of 60 countries, so you
can get around region blocks.
- Although you should check
the streaming provider's
terms of service first, okay?
- NordVPN has been
consistently highly rated.
They've been transparent about security
and they've been in
the business for years.
With their software, you can turn on
an automatic Kill Switch.
If your VPN connection
drops for any reason,
it'll block your device
from accessing the web,
so nothing leaks out.
It works on Windows, Mac,
Linux, iOS, and Android,
and it works on them
all at the same time.
You can have up to six devices
connected simultaneously.
- I don't know why you'd want to have
six devices connected simultaneously,
but if you want to,
good luck, it'll work.
- If you go to nordvpn.com/tomscott,
you'll get the best deal they're offering,
even if you're watching this
video far in the future,
when robots like me have
taken over the world.
- Sorry, what?
- And right now NordVPN has
a 30-day money back guarantee.
So if it turns out not
to be right for you,
no worries, they'll refund you.
That's nordvpn.com/tomscott.
- All right, I think that's a wrap,
folks. Let's shut it down.
- What?
No, no, no, there's more.
NordVPN's servers are diskless,
you can support this
channel by the signing up.
[slowing] You can, you can...
♫ Daisy, Daisy... ♫
- Thanks, I think I prefer it like this.